.
BACK TO YOU.
>> Sean: THANK YOU FOR THAT
REPORT.
WE WILL HAVE MORE LATER ON IN
THE SHOW.
JOINING US WITH MORE ON THE
STORM, GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS.
I KNOW YOU ARE UP BUT I KNOW YOU
ARE BUSY.
I HEARD YOU PUT PRESS
CONFERENCE.
TWO AND A HALF MILLION PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN ORDERED TO EVACUATE.
EVERY METEOROLOGIST I HAVE
SPOKEN TO SAYS THIS IS THE REAL
DEAL.
AND THE FLOODING COULD BE AS
HIGH AS 12 FEET.
STORM SURGES AND PEOPLE COULD
DIE AND TELL US WHAT THE PLAN
IS.
>> Governor DeSantis: YOU ARE
RIGHT, SEAN.
THIS IS A CATEGORY THREE.
IT WILL CERTAINLY BE A CATEGORY
FOUR AT SOME POINT BUT IT COULD
BE CATEGORY FOUR.
IT WILL PACK A PUNCH.
THAT IS GOING TO GENERATE HUGE
AMOUNT OF STORM SURGE AND THEN
WHAT IS EXPECTED TO HAPPEN IS
THE STORM IS GOING TO COME ON
SHORE AND THEN IT IS GOING TO
KIND OF SLOWED TO A CRAWL BUT
YES, IT WILL WEAKEN.
BUT IT WILL JUST PLOD ALONG.
WHAT THAT IS GOING TO DO, THAT
IS GOING TO DUMP MASSIVE AMOUNTS
OF RAIN.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAS BEEN
CHALLENGING WITH THIS IS WE
STARTED A COUPLE DAYS AGO WITH
LAND ARRIVAL PROTECTED IN NORTH
FLORIDA AND THE PANHANDLE AND
THAT WAS MOVED TO NORTH OF TAMPA
AND THEN TAMPA AND NOW THE MOST
RECENT GUIDANCE FOR THE NATIONAL
HURRICANE CENTER'S ARRIVAL AT
CHARLOTTE COUNTY AND SARASOTA
COUNTY BORDER BASICALLY.
BUT THERE'S GOING TO BE ANOTHER
UPDATE AT 11:00.
WE WILL SEE IF THAT TREND TO THE
EAST CONTINUES.
SEAN, YOU KNOW THAT PART OF THE
STATE VERY WELL.
THE FURTHER SOUTH IT HITS ON THE
PENINSULA THAT STARTS TO BRING
IN MORE MAJOR IMPACTS FOR PLACES
LIKE FORT MYERS AND NAPLES AND
THOSE COMMUNITIES AND ANOTHER
THING I THINK THAT IS GOING TO
BE CHALLENGING IS IT IS GOING TO
HIT AND THEN IT IS BASICALLY
GOING TO WIN ACROSS THE STATE
AND LIKELY EXIT ON THE ATLANTIC
COAST SOMETIME SOMEPLACE IN
CENTRAL OR NORTHEASTERN FLORIDA
AND THAT IS GOING TO BE
BASICALLY A TROPICAL STORM GOING
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
YOU'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT POWER
OUTAGES.
YOU ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT A
LOT OF RAIN AND FLOODING SO THIS
IS NOT JUST GOING TO BE LIMITED
TO THAT WHEREVER THE STORM MAKES
LANDFALL.
>> Sean: GOVERNOR, LET ME ASK
ASK YOU THIS.
AND I THINK YOU ARE SYMPATHETIC
LIKE I AM.
NO ONE WANTS TO BE
INCONVENIENCED LIKE THIS.
BUT I THINK YOU AGREE WITH ME.
PEOPLE WHO GENERALLY DON'T LIKE
TO BE TOLD WHAT TO DO.
THE WORST THING, THOUGH, THAT
COULD HAPPEN IS IF YOU TRY TO
RIDE THIS THING OUT.
AND YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO GET THE
LAST THING WE WANT AT THE END OF
THE DAY IS EVEN ONE PERSON DYING
FROM THIS STORM.
THAT IS PREVENTABLE IF PEOPLE
LEAVE.
NOW, IF YOU HAVE SET UP SHELTERS
ALL AROUND THE STATE OF FLORIDA,
ESPECIALLY IN THE AREAS THAT ARE
IN THAT CODE THAT WE HAVE UP ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE SCREEN.
TELL PEOPLE WHERE THEY CAN
COACH, WHAT YOU HAVE AVAILABLE,
AND WHAT ARE THE PLANS IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THIS?
>> Governor DeSantis: WELL,
SEAN, WE HAVE A SAYING DOWN HERE
IMPORTANT THAT YOU HIDE FROM THE
WIND BUT YOU RUN FROM THAT
WATER.
AND I THINK IN SITUATIONS LIKE
THIS, EVEN A CATEGORY FOUR
STORM, WE HAVE GREAT BUILDING
CODES.
A LOT OF OUR STRUCTURES IN
FLORIDA CAN WITHSTAND THAT AND
MOST PEOPLE'S HOMES, MAYBE NOT A
MOBILE HOME BUT MOST PEOPLE'S
HOMES CAN DO.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS STORM IS
THAT IT IS GOING TO GENERATE A
MASSIVE AMOUNT OF WATER AND A
SURGE AND THERE'S REALLY NO WAY
THAT YOU CAN COUNTERACT THAT IF
YOU ARE SOMEONE IN THAT BARRIER
ISLAND AND EVEN IF YOU ARE IN A
NICE STURDY HOME.
IF YOU GET 10 FEET OF STORM
SURGE, IF YOU LOOK AT THAT IS
GOING TO POTENTIALLY PUT YOUR
LIFE IN JEOPARDY.
WHAT WE HAVE SAID IS YOU DON'T
GET A MULLIGAN ON THIS.
YOU CAN ALWAYS GO BACKGROUND THE
STORM PASSES.
AND GET BACK IN YOUR HOME.
WE OFFICIALLY WANT YOU TO DO
THAT.
BUT THIS IS REALLY, REALLY
SIGNIFICANT AND YES, THERE ARE
SHELTERS IN ALL OF THESE
COUNTIES.
WE ALSO HAVE A DEAL WITH THE
STATE OF FLORIDA AND EXPEDIA.
PEOPLE CAN GO TO
EXPEDIA.com/FLORIDA AND
THERE'S HOTELS THAT ARE OFFERING
DEALS IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE OF FLORIDA.
ONE THING WE HAVE BEEN POINTING
OUT WHEN YOU'RE CALLED TO
EVACUATE, IT DOES NOT MEAN YOU
NEED TO LEAVE THE ENTIRE STATE.
IT DOES NOT MEAN YOU NEED TO THE
GHOST HUNDREDS OF MILES.
WHERE WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
WATER, OR ANYWHERE THAT IS
HIGHER GROUND IN A STURDY
STRUCTURE, YOU KNOW, YOU ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO RIDE IT OUT.
WHERE WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT IS
THE LOW LYING AREAS TO PLACES
THAT ARE VERY PRONE TO STORM
SURGE INTO THE FLOODING.
>> Sean: LET'S TALK ABOUT A
CONVERSATION WITH THE PRESIDENT
TO DATE AND EARLIER IN THE DAY,
THERE HAVE BEEN TALKS THAT THE
PRESIDENT SPOKE WITH MAYORS BUT
NOT YOU.
APPARENTLY THE PRESIDENT REACHED
OUT TO YOU TONIGHT.
CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THAT
CONVERSATION?
AND IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE
STORM, WHAT SUPPORT FLORIDIANS
CAN EXPECT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT?
>> Governor DeSantis: WELL,
SEAN, WHAT I SAID TODAY IS
IPHONE LINE IS OPEN WHEN
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND THEIR.
THEY ARE AT RISK LIKE THIS WE
ALL NEED TO WORK TOGETHER
REGARDLESS OF PARTY LINES.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
APPROVED A REQUEST FOR A
PRE-LANDFALL DECLARATION AND DID
THAT VERY QUICKLY.
SO WE ARE THANKFUL FOR THAT.
YOU KNOW, OF IS, AS IS THE
IMPACTS ARE KNOWN, THERE'S GOING
TO BE MORE REQUESTS,
PARTICULARLY FOR INDIVIDUALS
ASSISTANCE, FOR FLORIDIANS THAT
MAY HAVE BEEN DISPLACED.
YOU KNOW, IT IS MY SENSE THAT
THE A MISS PATIENT, YOU KNOW,
WANTS TO HELP.
I THINK HE REALIZED THAT THIS IS
A REALLY SIGNIFICANT SNOW HIM
AND THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE LOCALS.
WE WORK VERY WELL WITH THEM.
OF COURSE, THE STATE LEVEL, BUT
WE REALLY NEED EVERYONE WORKING
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
HAVE TO PUT NEEDS TENDED TO.
>> Sean: GOVERNOR KEMP LET'S
TALK ABOUT WHAT WE EXPECT IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THIS.
POWER OUTAGES OBVIOUSLY.
PROBABLY A SHORTAGE OF FOOD
WATER SUPPLIES.
SOME PEOPLE'S HOMES LIKELY WILL
BE DAMAGED PROBABLY.
NOT SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN
REPAIR.
WHAT ARE THE STEPS IN PLACE FOR
THE AFTERMATH AS THE STORM GOES
NORTH INTO OTHER STATES, MAYBE
HOPEFULLY OUT TO THE ATLANTIC
EVENTUALLY?
>> Governor DeSantis: WELL, OF
IS LOOK AS YOU MENTION, SEAN, WE
WANT PEOPLE TO BE SAFE WHEN IT
HITS AND SO THAT IS OUR NUMBER
ONE FOCUS NOW.
ONCE IT HITS, IF THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN NEED OF
RESCUE, YOU KNOW, WE GOT MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF ASSETS.
I GOT NATIONAL GUARD.
I GOT URBAN SEARCH AND RESCUE
TEAMS.
WE HAVE ASSETS FROM OTHER
STATES.
WE HAVE FLORIDA FISH AND WHILE
LEFT THAT HAVE WATER OPERATIONS.
I HAVE THE COAST GUARD HELPING
OUT.
SO THOSE OPERATIONS AS SOON AS
IT IS SAFE TO DO, THEY WILL GO
AND IF NEEDED, THEY WILL GO, TRY
TO HELP PEOPLE.
BUT ONCE YOU HAVE THAT SITUATION
TAKEN CARE OF, OF COURSE, YOU
WANT TO RESUME SERVICES AND SO
GETTING THE POWER BACK ON,
MAKING SURE FUEL IS IN THE GAS
STATIONS AND MAKING SURE PEOPLE
HAVE COMMUNICATIONS AND SO WE
HAVE NOW BETWEEN ALL OF OUR
UTILITY COMPANIES, IT DOES
PERSONNEL STATIONED READY TO GO
IN TO GET THE POWER BACK ON
THESE COMMUNITIES.
WE HAVE GOT FOLKS ON THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS FRONT THAT
HAVE FOLKS READY TO GO INTO
REPAIR ANY OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT MAY BE DAMAGED AT THE STATE
OF FLORIDA ALONE, WE HAVE
CONTRACTS TO BRING FUEL IN.
IF WE NEED THAT AND SO THOSE I
THINK GETTING EVERYBODY KIND OF
BACK TO NORMAL, YOU'RE RIGHT,
SEAN.
PEOPLE'S HOMES MAY BE TOTALLY
DESTROYED.
BUT FOR SLEEP MOST PEOPLE'S
HOMES WILL NOT BE.
THEY JUST NEED TO GET BACK IN
THERE AND HAVE NORMAL SERVICES
RESTORED.
SO ALL OF THAT IS PRE-STATE
RIGHT NOW.
AND AS SOON AS IS IT SAFE TO GO
IN, THEY WILL CLEAR THROAT ANDY
MOHR, THOSE LINEMEN INTO CAN TO
GET THE.
>> ON.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, GOVERNOR.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE EVERY
AGENCY IN FLORIDA AT YOUR
DISPOSAL.
FOR VOTE MOBILIZATION FOR THE
STORM.
I KNOW YOUR FELLOW COUNTRYMEN
FROM OTHER STATES ARE ALSO READY
TO HELP AS WELL.
FOR THOSE PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING
TO BE IN NEED.
OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE
WITH THE GREAT PEOPLE OF FLORIDA
AND PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO BE